speaking of funny and talented and
joining us
i didn't have a transition i got
desperate andy how are you
funny and talented and joining you yeah
right it works thanks sure sure no it
was nice it was nice
all right how have you been i've been
good how about you uh you know
fine you know i think uh i think i'm
ready for this pandemic to be over
yeah yeah it comes and goes in terms of
like it's
it's difficulty some days uh
feel okay and then other days i feel
like i'm gonna
just run screaming nude into the streets
yeah yeah
well what else do we talk about anything
else we should talk about
i don't know i think this pandemic has
gone on so long that you and i
have lost our ability to have a
conversation i yeah no
i don't i actually asked my phone to
marry me how did that
how would your phone say sad now
it doesn't feel very you know it does it
it's like i know what you look at
so no thanks
[Laughter]
well i think uh i think things are
looking up i swear to god there's going
to be more vaccine
i think we're i think i think we're i
see the light at the end of the tunnel i
swear to god i see the light at the end
of the tunnel which is the same thing i
said ten months ago
you'll get the vaccine i looked myself
up online i'm the last
talk show hosts are the bottom we're the
last priority
that's right which i think is actually
correct yes
yeah as it should be i'm scheduled to
get my vaccine
in three years yeah yeah i've always
said that you know
what we do here is the uh epitome of
non-essential personnel
exactly
you got to make a trim you know what i
found out other people
are supposed to get the vaccine for the
fifth time before you and i qualify to
get it for the first time
yeah the hole in their arm is so big
they just pour it in at that point yeah
i actually i i checked this out we're at
the bottom of the list
of all the talk show hosts really did
you know that
i did not i looked at it all the other
ones get to go first
because they've looked at the shows and
they said ours is the least essential
of pretty much non-essential shows oh
yeah well as long as wendy williams gets
it that's the important thing she's way
ahead of us you know who else is ahead
of us
the chew the talk show host where they
eat food
and i don't even is that still on the
air i don't even know if it's still in
the air but sure
the cast of the chew gets to go before
us yep yeah and nobody knows who the
cast is so you could just go in and say
you're on the chew
yeah if you want the vaccine for free
say hey i'm one of the
seven hosts of the chew the food
show that ripped off the name of the
view in a cute way
right you get to you get the vaccine
just say that
anyway i'm not complaining i'll get it
when i get it right